ALLEN OUR CHIRLA. ATKINS BATES
BAKER FOR JUST BRAD. BY GHETTO.
FOR TEN. DALLY DODD DORADO
EGGMAN GLAZER. GONZALEZ GROW.
HERTZBERG HUESO HER TADO JONES
CAN. AIR LEYVA MCGUIRE MULLIN.
MAN NEWMAN NIELSEN A CELLO BOW
PAN PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO.
SKINNER AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI
WIENER WILK. MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS
AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE
COOPER WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER
THIS AFTERNOON BY SENATOR
DORADO AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING. WE WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG BY SENATOR ROTH.
THIRTY ON JUST A SECOND AB CAN
GET THE MY ON. PLEASE PROCEED.
CREATOR GOD TODAY YOU WE GIVE
THANKS FOR SHELTERING DARK
PLACES THE RICH EARTH RECEIVES
GERMINATE THE CAVES THAT HARBOR
OUR ANCIENT ANCESTORS THE
SELLERS TO KEEP US SAFE FROM
TORNADOES THE WOUNDS THE
PROVIDER FIRST AND NOURISHMENT.
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE PAIN OF
SUFFERING WHICH CAN DEEPEN OUR
APPRECIATION OF LIFE AND
STRENGTHEN OUR CONNECTION TO
ONE ANOTHER. WE BLESSED
MUSHROOMS THAT GROW IN THE
DARK. AND HONEYSUCKLE THAT
SENDS ITS LUSCIOUS SENSE INTO
THE NIGHT. WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
THE DARKNESS THAT SUITS US TO
SLEEP. DARKNESS THE ANIMAL'S
REQUIRED HIBERNATION. WHEN WE
LOOK FOR THE POSITIVE IN ALL
THE SO CALLED DARK PLACES OF
OUR LIVES A MAN. PROBABLY
RELIGIOUS FOR THE FLAG OF THE
STATES IS AND TO THE REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY JUSTICE FOR ALL.
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE SENATOR
LIMóN AND TERN PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS AND WELCOME. MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR WE- IF
I IF I COULD EVER I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT WE HAVE A PRETTY
BUSY DAY TODAY AND SO IF YOU
COULD PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
AND BE. READY TO PROCEED THAT
WOULD BE APPRECIATED. SENATOR
ATKINS. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH COLLEAGUES TODAY IS A
SPECIAL DAY AND ONE THAT I HOPE
WE WILL TAKE THE TIME TO REALLY
PAY OUR RESPECTS TO SOMEONE WHO
IS RETIRING. I RISE TODAY TO
HONOR ONE OF OUR MOST TRUSTED
EMPLOYEES JENNY OROPEZA AND
PRESENT HER WITH THE SENATE
RESOLUTION CONGRATULATING HER
ON HER RETIREMENT. AND
COMMENDING HER FOR HER
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. GENIE HAS
BEEN MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS IN
PUBLIC SERVICE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SHE ALSO
SERVE FOR TWO YEARS AS THE
EDUCATION BUDGET CONSULTANT IN
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
HER PATIENTS INDEED IS IN
DURING. JENNY JOINED US IN THE
SENATE AS DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
HUMAN RESOURCES BACK IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND BROUGHT WITH HER A
CALM AND STABILITY. THAT WAS
INVALUABLE AND IMMEDIATE OVER
THE YEARS SHE'S LED OUR HUMAN
RESOURCES DEPARTMENT AND
SUPPORTED MORE THAN NINE
HUNDRED SENATE EMPLOYEES WITHIN
THE CAPITAL. THE LEGISLATIVE
OFFICE BUILDING AND SEVENTY SIX
DISTRICT OFFICES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND DID SO WITH THE
LAUGHTER AND THE SQUEALING OF
THE LITTLE ONES IN THE DAY CARE
CENTER AT THE HEART OF THE
LEGISLATIVE OFFICE BUILDING AS
THE SOUNDTRACK OF HER OFFICE.
THEN AGAIN MAYBE THAT'S WHAT
HELPED HER DEAL WITH ALL OF US
MEMBERS. WE COATED. FEENEY WAS
ONCE AGAIN THERE WITH HER CLM
AND STABLE APPROACH SHE HELPED
US WITH OUR STAFF NAVIGATE
STRESS PAPERWORK QUESTIONS. AND
SO MANY UNKNOWNS. AND NOW HERE
WE ARE HOPEFULLY ENTERING A
PERIOD OF CALM AND STABILITY.
AND SO NOW G. WANTS TO MOVE ON.
WITH HER PATIENCE AND STEADY
HAND I THINK ICE ROAD TRUCKING
OR HOSTAGE NEGOTIATING MAYBE IN
HER FUTURE. BUT IN ALL
SERIOUSNESS THOUGH I HAVE TO
SAY SHE WITH THIS RESOLUTION
AND WHAT IT STATES DO YOU HAVE
BEEN A VITAL SOURCE OF
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE. A
CALMING FORCE DURING PERIODS OF
EXTRAORDINARY TIME PRESSURE AND
A SOLID FOUNDATION DURING
PERIODS OF CHANGE. WHEN YOU
UNDOUBTEDLY OUR FRIEND THAT WE
ARE GOING TO MISS. ESPECIALLY
THE PRO TEM'S OFFICE WERE YOU
WERE OUR GO TO LIAISON TO HELP
WITH PERSONAL MATTERS. I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DEDICATION TO THE SENATE AND TO
THE LEGISLATURE. WE WISH YOU
ALL THE BEST IN YOUR RETIREMENT
AND I WOULD TELL MY COLLEAGUES.
SHE DID NOT WANT THIS
RECOGNITION TODAY I DID HAVE TO
FORCE THIS UPON HER. SO I DO
THINK IT THOUGH IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US. NOT TO LET
SOMEONE LEAVE WITHOUT THE
RECOGNITION THEY SO RICHLY
DESERVE SO JEANNIE- WHERE TO
GET. THERE SHE- HOPEFULLY
YOU'RE GONNA SAY SOMETHING HI
PLEASE- BUT WE WANT. TO WORLD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT'S BEEN A
PRIVILEGE AND AN HONOR TO SERVE
THE SENATE OF THE SENATORS AND
STAFF AND- I JUST APPRECIATE
ALL THE SUPPORT FROM THE PRO
TEM AND ALL THE MEMBERS OVER
THESE PAST FEW YEARS. AND
HOPEFULLY OUR PATHS WILL CROSS
IN THE FUTURE IF YOU EVER NEED
ANYTHING I'LL ALWAYS BE THERE
TO HELP- AND AGAIN THANK YOU.
SHE HAS. OKAY OKAY GOOD. IT
SENATOR NIELSEN WOULD YOU TO
TAKE THE PICTURE A LONG WITH
THE PRO TEM. A FORMER COURT.
OR.
YEAH CENTER NIELSEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SAY A FEW WORDS IN
REGARDS TO THIS RETIREMENT.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES ON THE
SENATE. IF I MAY. WE'VE SPOKEN
HERE TO JENNY'S NOR A LOYAL
SERVICE IN STATE EMPLOYMENT
OVER THE YEARS AND THE MANY
THINGS SHE SHE IS ACCOMPLISHED.
I HAVE A LIKE TO COME SOMETHING
THAT I'M FAMILIAR WITH. BUT
SHE'S DONE ON HER OWN TIME. FOR
MANY YEARS SHE AND I WERE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY BOARD
OF DIGNITY HEALTH. THE HEALTH
CARE FACILITY. THE COMMUNITY
BORDERS MORE THAN JUST THE-
HELPING THE INSTITUTION THAT
ACTUALLY IS A SHOT CALLING
BOARD THAT ANSWERS DIRECTLY TO
CATHOLIC HEALTHCARE WEST AS IT
WAS THEN CALLED FOR. BORDER IN
SAN FRANCISCO. AND SHE CHAIR.
THAT COMMUNITY BOARD FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS. AND WE MEET
NEEDING SO I KNOW SHE PUT HER
FULL DAY HERE. AND THEN CAME
THEIR- TO ATTEND TO THE CARE.
OF PEOPLE IN THE LARGE REGION
ANOTHER COPY. OF JENNY OR PAY.
CONGRATULATIONS TO MR BESSE FOR
HER RETIREMENT AND WE WISH YOU-
US SENATOR SKINNER. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS.
THANK YOU WHOA THAT'S
REALLY WHAT. OKAY THANK YOU MAY
FOR IS THE NUMBER LIKE DEVICE
HERE OF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S.
AND OUR TO MY M. WOMEN'S. THANK
AND RECOGNITION TO YOUR PAY FOR
HER YEARS OF STAY SERVICE PRESS
FOR YEARS OF SERVICE TO THE-
BUT ALSO. THE HER AS A LATINO.
WOMAN STATE SERVICE HER. UP IN
THE RANKS AS THE SHOWING ALL OF
US THAT. WOMEN CAN BE IN
EXECUTIVE ROLES IN THIS
INSTITUTION AND WITHIN THE
STATE AND WE CAN THRIVE AND WE
OFFER SO MUCH AND SO SHE IS AN
INCREDIBLE ROLE MODEL TO THE
OTHER WOMEN WITHIN STATE
SERVICE WHO ARE ALSO. HAVE THE
CAPACITIES TO DO SIMILARLY AND
WE WISH THEM ALL WELL BUT WE
WISH JEANNIE THE BEST IN HER WE
HOPE THAT SHE ENJOYS HER GOOD
TIME AS SHE HAS CHOSEN TO
RETIRE THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
PACING. SAN GROVE. THANK YOU
MATTER PRESIDENT AND YOU KNOW
THE LAST TWO YEARS I SERVED IN
THE REAP LEADER THERE ARE A LOT
OF THINGS THAT WE TO DEAL WITH
R. O. AND WHETHER IT WAS THINGS
THAT IT HAD THINGS WERE GOING
TO. AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT AND
REALLY ONLY EXPERIENCE I HAD
WITH MR PAYS A DURING THIS TIME
IN IN THIS LEGISLATURE AND SHE
IS OUTSTANDING SHE'S RESPONSIVE
SHE UNDERSTANDS HR AND HUMAN
RESOURCES- MECHANISMS AND HOW
THEY WORK AND THAT YOU KNOW IF
I EVER BUSINESS IT DOES HR IN
THE IN THE- PRIVATE INDUSTRY
AND BELIEVE ME- DEALING IN THE
PRIVATE INDUSTRY ON HR ISSUES
IS A LOT DIFFERENT IN A LOT
EASIER THAN DEALING WITH HR
ISSUES HERE IN THIS BUILDING-
ESPECIALLY WHEN ALL OF US WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT IT. ARE REALLY
EMPLOYEES OF THE RULES RIGHT SO
WE'RE TECHNICALLY THEIR
EMPLOYEES TO IN CAN YOU JUST
IMAGINE WHEN AN HR PERSON HAS
TALKED TO A SENATOR ABOUT HR
ISSUES SO- I CAN TELL YOU THAT
SHE'S BALANCES FAIR SHE'S KIND
SHE LOOKS AT ALL AVENUES AND
SHE REALLY JUST WAS A WONDERFUL
PERSON TO DEAL WITH THE LAST
FEW YEARS- THAT I WAS ABLE TO
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY WITH
TODAY TO DO WITH YOU AND I
JUST- WISH YOU NOTHING BUT THE
BEST IN YOUR RETIREMENT MISTER
WONDERFUL LIFE. SENATOR.
ACTUALLY MY WORD IT IS OUR BEEN
ADDED MELODY ARE YOU CAN SEE
WITH A INCREDIBLE WORK THERE
WITH JEANNIE ON. A WOMAN IF YOU
PUT MY TAX- I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS I KNOW YOU'VE TALKED
ABOUT IT IN. THROUGH I. AND
TENSE WITH WITH GRAY. AND PER
BY BUT ALSO THE GOOD TO. AND
HOW TO ALL THE PERSON THROUGH
ALL THEIR BIG IPHONE. I'M
HAVING KIDS AND GETTING THEIR-
MAKING FAMILIES IN THIS A
FAMILY SO- I PER APPRECIATE S.
AS IN YEARS STAFF AND NOW IS A-
OF. WHAT WHAT YOU'VE DONE OVER
THE- SO VERY FEW WERE BUT A
REMARKABLE CA RESOURCE FACES A
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSS OR DEBATE. C.
CONGRATULATE ON YOUR RETURN AND
BEST WISH FROM ALL OF US WERE
GOING TO MISS YOU HERE IN THIS.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
WITHOUT OBJECTION REMOVED TO
THE SENATE THIRD READ READING
SR TWENTY THREE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR DRAWS- ARE
YOU PREPARED. YES SHE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION TWENTY THREE BY
SENATOR DORADO RELATIVE TO
CINCO DE MAYA WEEKS SENATOR
RUSSELL THE FLOOR'S YOURS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. AS CHAI THE LATINO
CARE ACT IT IS MY HONOR TO BE
pMEMORIALIZES CINCO TAMAYO AS A
SIGNIFICANT DATE IN MEXICAN AND
CALIFORNIA HISTORY. ON MAY
FIFTH EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO AT THE
BOTTOM THE BLUE BLAH IN MEXICO
A SMALL ARMY OF INDIGENOUS
MEXICANS OUTNUMBERED AND
OUTGUNNED. FORMULATED A STRONG
RESISTANCE AND DEFEATED A WORLD
POWER OF FRENCH COLONIAL FORCE
MUCH LARGER BETTER TRAINED AND
EQUIPPED. THEY WERE LED BY
PRESIDENT BENEATH A LOT IS THE
FIRST INDIGENOUS PRESIDENT IN
NORTH AMERICA AND DEFENDER OF
MEXICO'S PROHIBITION OF SLAVERY.
PRESIDENT WHAT IS AND PRESIDENT
ABRAHAM LINCOLN WE'RE ENGAGED
AND APPARENTLY A DIFFERENT WAR
WITH DIFFERENT FORCES YET OVER
A SIMMER SIMILAR MATTER
FLAVORING. WHAT IS REFUSE TO
ACCEPT SLAVERY A DEMAND THAT
LED TEXANS TO PROVOKE A WAR
WITH MEXICO. DESPITE A SEVERE
LACK OF RESOURCES THE MEXICAN
ARMY ZEAL AND DETERMINATION TO
BE FREE FROM COLONIZATION MADE
THEM VICTORIOUS. WE RECOGNIZING
THE MILE BECAUSE IT SERVES AS A
SYMBOL OF OUR MEXICAN CULTURE
RESILIENCE AND CHARACTER. THINK
OF THE MEYER REMINDS US THAT
THE FOUNDATION OF ANY NATION
AND OUR STATE IS ITS PEOPLE.
THEIR SPIRIT AND COURAGE IN THE
FACE OF ADVERSITY. AND IN THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO SACRIFICE EVEN
LIFE ITSELF IN THE PURSUIT OF
FREEDOM AND LIBERTY FOR ALL.
BUT THE NOSE OF MEXICAN DESCENT
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE CHALLENGED
THE FRONTIERS OF SOCIAL
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
BUT THE MOST OF STRENGTHENED
AND UPLIFTED OUR STATE IN
COUNTLESS WAYS. WE ARE FIFTEEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS OF LATINO
DESCENT. WE ARE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF ISSUES THAT IMPACT
OUR COMMUNITY'S LIVELIHOOD AND
WELL BEING. AS WELL AS THE
LIVELIHOOD OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
WHO DEFENDED PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND HEALTH CARE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS IN THE
BATTLE VER PROP ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN BALLOT MEASURE. DURING
THE PANDEMIC WE CONTINUE TO
WATCH OUT FOR THE EALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR FARMWORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES AS THEY FEED US
IN THE NATION. ALTHOUGH
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN HOME OUR
HOME FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS WE
NOW HAVE THE FIRST LATINO U. S.
SENATOR ALEX BY VIA. ON THIS
DAY WHAT WE RECOGNIZE THE
COURAGE THE STRENGTH AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE SYMBOLISM OF
THE VICTORY AT BUT BY OTHER
PEOPLE HAVE LONG WAVELENGTH BY
MEXICAN FORCES. THE LATINO
CAUCUS IS PROUD TO SHARE WITH
YOU THE COURAGE STRENGTH AND
RESILIENCE THAT IS EMBODIED IN
THE SPIRIT OF NINE LATINO
LEADERS WE HAVE SELECTED TO
RECEIVE OUR ANNUAL. SPRING OF A
RECOGNITION THE BIOGRAPHIES
BIOGRAPHIES OF THE NINE LET THE
IN THE SPIRIT AWARD RECIPIENTS
CAN BE FOUND ON THE PROGRAMS
MADE AVAILABLE TO ALL SENATORS.
THEY ARE AN EXCEPTIONAL GROUP
OF LEADERS WHO FEEL WE FEEL
PROUD TO RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR
ACHIEVEMENTS. IN HEALTH AND
SCIENCE LITERATURE AND
JOURNALISM RADIO BROADCASTING
AND PHILANTHROPY. THE LABOR
MOVEMENT COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT
THE ARTS AND BUSINESS THEY ARE
BOLD THEY ARE INSPIRED. AND
THEIR COMPASSIONATE LEADERS
THAT TRULY EMBODY A LOT THE IN
THE SPIRIT AND I'M TO SHARE
THEIR ACCOMPLISHMENTS WITH OUR
CAPITAL COMMUNITY. THANK YOU.
SENATOR PENN. THANK YOU MADAM
FOR SAID I TO AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. TWENTY IS CHAIR
OF THE ASIA PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND I THINK
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS
ANGELES- FOR. DISCUSS THE
HISTORY OF SINKING TAMAYO
THINKING ABOUT LET US REFLECT
ON THE SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE MEXICAN
LATINO COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA'S CULTURE AND
HISTORY. AND AS A REMINDER TO
ALL OF US THAT THE FOUNDATION
OF OUR STATE IS BUILT BY ITS
PEOPLE. DAPI COMMITTEE IS PROUD
TO HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
WORKING WITH THE LATINO CAN BE
TO FIGHT FOR FREEDOM AND
AGAINST INJUSTICES AND THAT'S-
THE FOUNDATION OF CINCO TAMAYO.
AND EARLY ON. HUNDREDS
IMMIGRATION RESTRICTIONS IT'S
ENOUGH LANDOWNERSHIP LAWS
BROUGHT JOB AND NEXT AMERICAN
CAMINO TOGETHER TO FOR AND TO
RAISE FOR. AND FARMING
COMMUNITIES IN THE CENTRAL
IMPERIAL VALLEY'S. DURING THE
NINETEEN SIXTY DELANO GRAPE
STRIKE CEDAR CHAVEZ DOLORES
HUERTA WORKED WITH TOGETHER
WITH PHILIPPINE LEADERS.
PUTTING PHILIP. VERA CRUZ AND
LARRY AT LONG FIGHT FOR SOCIAL
AND WORKERS RIGHTS UNDER ONE OF
THE HISTORY STRONG THIS MULTI
ETHNIC COALITIONS UNITED FARM
WORKERS. AND LATINO BLACK AND
ASIAN AMERICAN YOUTH CAME
TOGETHER DURING THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES TO FIGHT
FOR RELEVANT EDUCATION WHICH
LED TO THIS TALISMAN OF ETHNIC
STUDIES. IN OUR UNIVERSITIES.
AS I FOR YOUR SUPPORT PRESS ARE
TWENTY THREE TO RECOGNIZE CINCO
DE MILO AND TO HONOR THE
CULTURE AND HISTORY OF THE
LATINO. AND TO SANDON
SOLIDARITY WITH THE LATINO
COMMUNITY AND IT'S A DEEP
HISTORY. NOT ONLY HERE JUST IN
THE US BUT ACTUALLY IN- MEXICO
AND OTHER COUNTRIES AND HOW
THAT CAME TOGETHER TO THEN LEAD
TO. OUR MUTUAL FIGHT FOR
FREEDOM AND JUSTICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I FOR NINE
THANK YOU. SENATOR NIELSEN.
PRESIDENT GENTLEMAN THAT WOULD
ALLOW TO SETTLE THIS. OUR GOOD
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES HAS
GIVEN US A. AND ALLOW ME THEN
HAVING HAD A FEW OKAY. DEBATE
UNTIL A MEXICO ON SECOND THE
MILE. TAYLOR WAS THE SAYS CITY
OF THE TOWN OF BENICIA AND
SOLANO COUNTY AND ONCE A YEAR
WE WOULD EXCHANGE TRIPS THOSE
UNTIL IT WOULD COME TO BENICIA
AND WE FROM THE NATION WOULD GO
TO TOTAL. AND ONE OF THOSE
YEARS  WAS ASKED TO DELIVER A
DISCOURSE OF. THIS IN THE PLOT
TO NON SICK OF THE MY- WHAT A
HOW EXPERIENCE. THAT WORKS. NOW
I WANTED TO PRINT. IN SPANISH
UNFORTUNATELY I'VE BEEN DOWN
THERE ABOUT THREE DAYS WHICH
TAKES ABOUT THREE DAYS TO BE
ABLE TO THANK VANISH SO I CAN
SPEAK SPANISH. THAT IT WAS VERY
MOVING TO ME TO SEE THE
ENTHUSIASM OF THE WHOLE
COMMUNITY THOSE THOUSAND. FROM
THE VERY YOUNGEST CHILDREN
BABES IN ARMS. THE VERY OLDEST
AND HOW THEY REVERED THAT
HISTORY THAT HISTORIC MOMENT.
IN THE AFFIRMATION OF THE STATE
AND THE COUNTRY OF MEXICO. IT
WAS VERY VERY MOVING INDEED AND
I BORROWED FROM KENNEDY UNLIKE
CLOSING REMARKS AND NOT
DISCOURSE SO I SAID SO YOU KNOW
I'M READY TO. THAT MEANT
SOMETHING TO THEM THE FOLKS IN
A LOT MORE TO ME TO FEEL THAT
EMPATHY. TO MEXICO. SENATE WEST
OF. THANK YOU PRESIDENT MA'AM
AND I RISE THE OF SR TWENTY
THREE OH ONE THANK AUTHOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN THE LATINO CAUCUS
AND ALSO THIS AND MEASURE AND
ALSO- THE IMPORTANT OF THIS
MESS TO CONTINUE TO EDUCATE
ABOUT THE IMPORTANT SIGNIFICANT
OF THE STATE IN HISTORY- IT HAS
BEEN COMPLETELY MISTER
MISREPRESENTED AS THE
INDEPENDENCE. OF MEXICO OR
OFTENTIMES. PEOPLE. REALLY
REDUCE ITS IT'S US VALUE BUT
TAKE TOOK OVER BY INDUSTRY THE
COME TO KNOWN BY SO AND SO
CIRCLES SINGLE TO DRINK GO. AND
PEOPLE LOS THE SIGNAL OF SIMPLE
DATE AND IT SHOULD BE IMPORTANT
CALL NOT ASK WHY DO WE SELL A
SING DE MAYO CALIFORNIA ISN'T
THE- AN EVENT THAT. IN MY. WELL
RECALL IN WHAT WAS HAVE. IN MY
IN. INTERIM EIGHT SIX TWO.
LINCOLN WAS PRESS OF THE STATES.
BENITO IS WAS. OF THE- WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN THE UNITED STATES
STRING EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO THE
CIVIL WAR. AND THERE WAS A
THERE WAS A FIGHT. FOUR OF THE
TO REUNITE THE COUNTRY BUT THE
ISSUE WAS SLAVERY. AND THERE
WAS AN UNDERSTANDING THAT
FRANCE FRANCE HAD UNITED WITH
THE CONFEDERATE SIDE TO
REINTRODUCE SLAVERY INTO MEXICO.
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ORIGINAL CALIFORNIANS OF
MEXICAN ORIGIN WERE FERVENTLY
ANTI SLAVERY. AND ONE OF THE
OUTCOMES OF STATEHOOD IN
EIGHTEEN FIFTY OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIRST STATE
IN US HISTORY TO BE MADE A
STATE WITHOUT A COMPANION SLAVE
STATE. IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN THE
GOLD RUSH THAT PUSHED. THE US
GO TO. RATIFY CAL STATE THERE
BY THE BUILDINGS HAD GOLDEN
SINCE SO I'M IN AND OUT OF
ANOTHER. ASPECT IN THAT.
STATEHOOD CAL REALLY MAY THE
END OF NEW STATES BECAUSE IT.
IT ALLOWED EVENTUALLY FOR
ABRAHAM LINCOLN TO GET ELECTED
AND ALLOWED FOR THERE TO BE. A
MAJORITY IN CONGRESS THAT WAS
FAVORABLE TO ENDING SLAVERY IN
AMERICA AND S CALIFORNIANS
HAVE A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE IN
ELIMINATING SLAVERY IN THE US
BUT ALSO BECAUSE OF THE SUPPORT
OF CALIFORNIANS. IN MEXICO IT
ALSO MEANT THAT SLAVERY WAS NOT
INTRODUCED INTO INTO MEXICO
EVEN AT A TIME WHEN THE US SEEM
TO BE SO. TO PROVIDE WITH US
WITH AN INTERNAL CIVIL WAR.
THERE WAS ALSO THE PROVIDE
SUPPORT. IN MEXICO AND- SENT
MONEY SUPPORT AND EVEN. TO
FIGHT THE FRENCH. AND THEY
ENDED UP SENDING A GOLD SORT. A
FULL OF- EMERALDS IN ROOM AND-
WAS A BEAUTIFUL DIAMOND AND- A
MENTAL SOARED WAS SENT TO. THEN
GENERAL. THE VICTOR THE FOR-
THE SENATE WILSON THAT TO. HE
NAY RECEIVED BECAUSE AGAIN IT
BUT- WAS JUST A SYMBOL OF HOW
CAL WAS OF. IN RARE CAPE
SLAVERY IN THE NORTH OF. AND- A
OF THAT MEXICO SELA- A VICTORY
OVER CA. SO IT'S OFTEN
EMISSIONS IS A AS A VICTORY
OVER A DEPEND BUT IT REALLY. A
VOTING COLOGNE AND THE SOME
THAT WE'VE ALWAYS IN THE
AMERICA THAT WERE ARE A WE
REGION A CO PEOPLE. AND WE
ALWAYS HAVE TO REMEMBER HOW
THEY THE UNITED AMERICAS HAVE
ALWAYS STOOD TOGETHER. AND
SHOULD CONTINUE TO WORK TO IN
THIS A MESSAGE ABOUT TELL. OF
CALIFORNIA STORY. THAN ABOUT.
SUCCESS AS A LEADER. IN THE
AMERICAS AND THE HAS SO WELL
BEEN SO SUCCESS. IN THAT ROLE
NOT ONLY CULTURAL PROJECT AS
WELL SO THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HISTORY AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS VERY MEMORABLE OCCASION.
THANK YOU WHEN PRESIDENT.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND I APOLOGIZE
AND FOR MY REPETITIVENESS BUT
THAT'S WHAT I GET FOR FOLLOWING
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO BUT
AS- CARELESSLY BLACK CAUCUS WHO
WE TRULY SOME SR TWENTY. ARE
HAS STATED- A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE YEARS AGO A WELL EQUIPPED
FRENCH ARMY LOSS TO UNDER ARMED
GROUP OF MEXICAN TROOPS IN THE
BATTLE OF THE PROBLEM AND MAY
FIFTH EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO WHILE
MOST AMERICANS MISTAKENLY
ASSOCIATE AGAIN SINGLE THE MILE
WITH MEXICANS INDEPENDENCE OR
DAY TO DINE ON DELICIOUS
MEXICAN FOOD OR IN MY CASE
CONSUME FINE TEQUILA. THIS IS
MOVING ITS OF THIS DATA LIES
WITHIN THE STORY OF THE BATTLE
BATTLE OF THE PROBLEM AND THE
TEAM OF WAR SLAVERY PATRONIZED
PRITCHARD HIS OWN AND A FIVE
FOR FREEDOM AND THE BALLOT OF
THE OCCURRED IN THE MIDST AS AS
SENATOR HUESO STATE DURING THE
CIVIL. AND ALL THE FRENCH CARE
DID TAKE ENOUGH POSITION IN THE
U. S. CIVIL WAR NAPOLEON OF
FRANCE SAW THE WAR AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT THE
CONFEDERACY WHAT WEAPONS IN
RETURN FOR COTTON AND OTHER
CROPS NAPOLEON BELIEVE THE U.
S. WAS TOO OCCUPIED AND IT'S
ALL MORE TENER AND SENT TROOPS
INTO MEXICO IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY
TWO HOPING TO DEFEAT THE
MEXICAN TOMORROW THEM A GOV.
WHICH IT UP SLAVERY SB FIFTY IN
ADVANCE. EXCO VICTORY OVER FOR.
AND THE BATTLE OF LIKE OCCURRED
I MEAN BY THANKS SAY FRAN ARE
FOR OUR FOR FROM. IN EIGHTEEN I
SHOULD SAY THE COMPETITOR INPUT
TO OVER OF THE U. S. CIVIL WAR
AS WELL AS A- SLAVERY. THERE
WERE OVER FIFTY. AMERICANS OF
pPOPULAR IT WILL HERE TODAY WHO
CONTINUE TO MAKES INTO CON TO
EVERY ASK OF IS ANALYZE
SIGNALED OFF US AN OPPORTUNITY
REFLECT ON THE RESILIENCE IN
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE NOT ONLY BY
MEXICAN TROOPS A PROBLEM. BUT
ALSO ON THE COURAGE AND
ACHIEVEMENTS OF LATINOS HERE IN
THIS COUNTRY THIS WEDNESDAY LET
US EDUCATE OURSELVES ON THE
RUE HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE OF
THIS DAY AND CONTINUE TO
CELEBRATE THE INSURMOUNTABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS MAY BAR LATINO
BROTHERS AND SISTERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT THE
U. S. AS CALIFORNIANS WE SHOULD
ALL BE MINDFUL OF THE MANY
LESSONS OF COURAGE SACRIFICE
AND FAITH IN THE STORY OF
SINGLE TOMORROW I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. SENATOR. THANK
YOU BETTER PRESIDENT THAT I'VE
ON BEHALF OF THE L. G. B. T. QU
TO ALSO HONOR AND REMOTE ON
SENATE RESOLUTION SR THREE.
DOLLARS COMMUNITY IN THE L. L.
G. T. COULD HAVE A HAVE A HAVE
A IS. WE OFTEN TALK ABOUT THE
C. TOMORROW IN THE BACK IN THE
TO THAT THE M. DONALD SPIRIT OF
THE MEXICAN AMERICAN PEOPLE-
ALSO COMES ACROSS IN OUR L. G.
B. BRETHREN AS WELL- AND WE
KNOW THAT WHEN LOOK TO
VICTIMIZE THOSE MAY BE OF A LOT
TO AS WELL L. G. B. THEY. IT
WASN'T SUCCESSFUL BUT THAT
CREEK PAVE THE PATH FOR OTHERS
TO FOLLOW BEHIND- AND IN THIS
OWN HOUSE WE'VE HAD SUCH
NOTABLE PEOPLE AS A- NOW CHIEF
REJECTS BAD JOHN BETTIS RICARDO
LARA OUR INSURANCE COMMISSIONER.
MYSELF BUT TODD GLORIA THE
MAYOR OF. I SEEM TO BE A GO-
AND WE ALSO SEE A SABRINA
CERVANTES THE MOTHER OF
TRIPLETS WHILE IN THE HOUSE IN
A DOUBLE SPIRIT INDEED SO I
RISE ON BEHALF OF THE LGBT
CAUCUS TO TALK ABOUT OUR HARED
EXPERIENCE AND THE RICHNESS AND
DIVERSITY THAT EXISTS WITHIN
THE MEXICAN AMERICAN PEOPLE I
ASK FOR YOUR I. ON SR TWENTY
THREE. SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF SR TWENTY THREE. ARE
THERE ARE STRIKING SIMILARITIES
BETWEEN THE OUTNUMBERED MEXICAN
ARMY'S MILITARY VICTORY OVER
THE POWERFUL FRENCH ARMY. ON
MAY FIFTH EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO
AND MANY JEWISH UNDERDOG
STORIES THAT ARE STRONG
INFLUENCES IN JEDIISM TODAY.
THE BIBLICAL STORY OF DAVID AND
GOLIATH ESTHER DEFEATING HEYMAN
AND THE PERM IN THE FORM STORY.
THAT'S MOST SIMILAR TO THE
NATIVE MACCABEES SURPRISING
MILITARY VICTORY AND THE
HANUKKAH STORY. THE FIGHT
AGAINST COLONIALISM AND
PERSECUTION AS MANIFESTED IN
DIFFERENT FORMS FOR MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT HUMAN
HISTORY IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
HOLIDAYS LIKE SINGLE TAMAYO. TO
TAKE TIME TO CELEBRATE
RESILIENCE TECHNOLOGY PROGRESS
AND TO RESET OUR QUEST FOR
LIBERATION. THE BATTLE OF PLATE
WILL ALSO LEAD TO SAFETY FOR
MANY JEWS- AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW
THAT- SPAIN WAS NOT EXACTLY THE
BEST PLACE IN THE WORLD.
PRODUCE IMPACT THE SPANISH
INQUISITION AND EXPULSION AND
REQUIREMENTS- OF JEWS- FOR- FOR
CENTURIES- WAS ONE OF THE WORST
EPISODES- IN JEWISH HISTORY-
THE SPAIN FORBADE THE PRACTICE
OF JUDAISM FORCED CONVERSION.
AND UNFORTUNATE SPANISH
INQUISITION HAD SPREAD TO
MEXICO. WHERE COMMUNITY OF THE
SECRET JEWS WERE LIVING HIDING
THEIR FATE. OF THE MEXICAN
VICTORY ON SINGLE TAMAYO
TRIGGERED A SERIES OF EVENTS
THAT LED TO A RELIGIOUS
TOLERANCE MANDATE IN MEXICO.
AND THE RENEWAL OF JEWISH
RELIGIOUS PRACTICE. INDEED OVER
THE YEARS THIS POLICY HAS
INFLUENCED BY MANY JEWS WERE
FLEEING EASTERN EUROPE AND THE
POGROMS MANY CAN'T WE KNOW
ABOUT THE MANY JEWS INCLUDING
MY- GRANDPARENTS AND GREAT
GRANDPARENTS WHO FLED THE
POGROMS IN EASTERN EUROPE. AND
CAME TO THE U. S. BUT MANY JEWS
CAN'T WENT TO MEXICO FROM
EASTERN EUROPE TO SEEK FREEDOM
AND IT WERE THE JEWS AND THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY IN MEXICO-
NUMBERS TODAY ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND IT'S A SIZABLE
COMMUNITY. THE RESILIENCE
DEMONSTRATED AT THE BATTLE OF
PUEBLA HAS MANIFESTED IN OUR
CALIFORNIA LOOK- LATINO
POPULATION AS WELL.
CONTRIBUTING TO OUR STAY IN
MANY MANY WAYS OF COURSE ON THE
TEAM OR COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE- HAVE CHAMPION SOME
OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT AND
IMPACTFUL PROGRESSIVE REFORMS.
THANK CALIFORNIA HISTORY AND
THAT IS A CORD. SO THIS SINGLE
IN MY- WE THANK YOU SELL OUR
LATINO COMMUNITY THERE'S AN AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
SENATOR ALSO YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
AM HONORED TO CELEBRATE OUR
MEXICAN AND LATINO HERITAGE IN
CONTRIBUTIONS AND I THINK MANY
OF YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
COMMENTS WE HAVE A PROFOUND
RESPONSIBILITY TO PREVAIL
AGAINST ALL THE FORCES THAT
WOULD PREVENT SOME OF US FROM
ACHIEVING THE CALIFORNIA DREAM.
WE HAVE MANY MANY MORE GIRLS
AND BOYS YOU CAN BE THE HIGH
MAN HADLEEN FRANK LIMA MERRY
SALAS OR JEANNIE OROPEZA.
TOGETHER WE WILL IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR LATINOS AND
ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BAKER HI PORGES I BRADFORD FIVE
CABRERA HI CORTESE FIVE DALLY I
DODD. HI TORONTO BY EGGMAN I
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH
FIVE HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. HI
HER TADO FIVE JONES I KAMLAGER
I LAYERED I LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE
AYE MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF
BOTH. HI PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO I SKINNER HI
AMBERG HI WHAT KIND OF SKI FIVE
WIENER AYE WILK HI. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ THE NAMES OF THE HONOREES
WHO ARE RECEIVING THE LATINO
SPIRIT AWARD. DR JEFFREY GARCIA
ACHIEVEMENT IN HEALTH AND
SCIENCE HE IS A DOCTOR OF
OPTOMETRY PRACTICING IN THE
MORE THAN VOLUNTEERS HIS TIME
SERVICES TO PROVIDE CARE TO
THOSE IN THE UNITED STATES AND
ABROAD. RAINER GRANDE
ACHIEVEMENT IN LITERATURE AND
ADVOCACY SHE IS THE AUTHOR OF
THE DISTANCE BETWEEN US A
MEMOIR ABOUT HER LIFE BEFORE
AND AFTER RIDING IN THE UNITED
STATES FROM MEXICO AS AN
UNDOCUMENTED CHILD IMMIGRANTS.
MARIA YOU KNOW NOT YOU KNOW
HOSA ACHIEVEMENT IN JOURNALISM
AND MEDIA SHE IS A PD PEABODY
AWARD WINNING JOURNALIST WHO
COVERS. ISSUES IMPORTANT TO
LATINO COMMUNITY AND CIVIL AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES FACING A
MORE DIVERSE AMERICA. HI AMY
HOW DEAN ACHIEVEMENT IN RADIO
BROADCASTING AND PHILANTHROPY
HE IS THE SPANISH LANGUAGE
VOICE OF THE LOS ANGELES
DODGERS AND- WHAT AND THE
LONGEST SERVING BROADCASTER IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL. CARLOS
AND LINDA LOOK READING
ACHIEVEMENT AND COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT. THEY FOUNDED THE
STATE'S OUR CHAVEZ SERVICE
CLUBS IN TWO THOUSAND ONE A
CIVIC AND COMMUNITY SERVICE
ORGANIZATION FOR YOUTH IN SAN
DIEGO. FRANK B. LIMA.
ACHIEVEMENT IN PUBLIC SERVICE
HE IS A LOS ANGELES FIREFIGHTER
AND THE TWELFTH THE GENERAL
SECRETARY TREASURER OF THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
FIREFIGHTERS. PADDY RODRIGUEZ
ACHIEVEMENT IN BUSINESS AND
PHILANTHROPY SHE'S AN
ENTREPRENEUR TV PRODUCER
ACTIVIST AND AUTHOR OF THE
CHILDREN'S EDUCATIONAL BOOKS
LILY BROS. AMERICANS YES SALAS
ACHIEVEMENT IN PUBLIC SERVICE
SHE HAS SERVED THE PEOPLE OF
CHULA VISTA AND SAN DIEGO FOR
DECADES. SIMONE SILVA.
ACHIEVEMENT IN ARTS HE IS AN
ARTIST SPEAKER AND AUTHOR WHO
INSPIRES OTHERS TO OVERCOME
THEIR OBSTACLES EMBRACE THEIR
INDIVIDUALITY AND REGAIN THEIR
CREATIVE CONFIDENCE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. UNFORTUNATELY WEEK
WE BECAUSE OF COVERED WE
COULDN'T HAVE THESE INDIVIDUALS
HERE TODAY BUT WILLMAKE SURE
THAT THEY GET THEIR AWARDS AND-
NEXT YEAR HOPEFULLY WILL BE
ABLE TO DO THIS ON THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOVING ON
TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES WITHOUT OBJECTION
PURSUANT TO JOINT ROLE THREE
THREE POINT ONE. JOINT RULE
SIXTY ONE WILL BE SUSPENDED TO
ALLOW THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TO MEET AND REPORT SB SIX FIVE
FIVE AFTER THE FISCAL DEADLINE.
THIS REQUEST HAS BEEN APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR THE WEEK OF APRIL TWENTY
SIXTH THROUGH THE TWENTY NINTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE FOLLOWING RESOLUTIONS WILL
BE PLACED ON TODAY'S SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR. ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY SEVEN ACR FIFTY FOUR.
ITEM SIXTY EIGHT. AC ARE SIXTY
ONE. AND ITEM AT SIXTY NINE AC
ARE SIXTY TWO. MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE. SECOND
READING FILE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL THREE
EIGHTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS SIX
FORTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS FOR
THIRTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS
SEVEN NINETY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL EIGHT
WITH AMENDMENT SIXTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS FIVE SIXTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS SEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE
BILL FIVE NINETY ONE CAN'T
REALLY MISSILE. WILL BE DEEMED
READ MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN.
SENATOR ATKINS THE FLOOR'S
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DEAN BOARDS AS
DIRECTOR OF FACILITIES PLANNING
CONSTRUCTION AND MANAGEMENT AT
CDC ARE. IN THE RULES COMMITTEE
HEARING IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
WERE RAISED BY MEMBERS ABOUT
RECENT FACILITY CLOSURES BY
CDCR. MR BOARD WAS NOT DIRECTLY
INVOLVED IN ANY OF THOSE
DECISIONS TO CLOSE FACILITIES.
SEVERAL OTHER CDC ARE
APPOINTEES ARE CURRENTLY
AWAITING SENATE CONFIRMATION
THE RULES COMMITTEE HAS ASKED
THE DEPARTMENT TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY SENATORS
DURING THE HEARING. AND WE WILL
BE RECEIVING ADDITIONAL
RESPONSES FROM THEM BEFORE THE
SECRETARY OF CORRECTIONS IS
TAKEN UP FOR CONFIRMATION.
MISTER GEORGE WAS APPROVED BY
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
APRIL FOURTEENTH ON A FOUR ZERO
VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES BAKER FIVE
FOR JUST. BRADFORD HI CABALLERO
HIGH COURT TESTING AYE DALLY.
DODD FIVE TERRAZZO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HUESO AYE HER TADO.
JONES I KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE
LEYVA I MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ I
MEN I NEWMAN. I NIELSEN FIVE A
TOTAL OF BOTH. I PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO. HI
SKINNER. HI AMBERG HI WHAT
KASKY I WIENER AYE WILK I.
PLEASE READ THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES FOR JEFF. DALLY BYE I.
GROVE I- TADO. FIVE THIRTY FIVE
NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MEMBERS ARE GONNA
MOVE ONTO UNFINISHED BUSINESS
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY. SENATOR
SKINNER. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE.
SENATE BILL NINETY TWO BY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY DID
YOU EVEN KNOW JUSTICE AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. SENATOR SKINNER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB NINETY TWO
IS A- TECHNICAL CLEAN UP IN THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF SECURE TRACK.
OF FOLLOWING THE BUDGET ACTION
WE TOOK LAST YEAR. THAT
REALIGNED THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE SO AGAIN IT IS
SOME TECHNICAL CLEANUP AND
STATUTORY CHANGES NECESSARY. TO
IMPLEMENT THAT ACT WHICH WE
PASSED AS PART OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY OR THAT TRANSACTION WE
PASSED AS PART OF TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT. THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE INTAKE HAS
BEEN GRADUALLY. MOVING PAST
ACCEPTING NEW WORDS AND IT WILL
CLOSE FULLY ON JULY OR RATHER
IT WILL STOP ACCEPTING NEW
PLACEMENTS FULLY ON JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WHICH MEANS
THAT IT WILL NO LONGER BE A
PLACEMENT OPTION. SO AS OUR
ACTION IN THE BUDGET
ENVISIONED- WE NEED TO CLARIFY
THAT WE ARE. THAT WE NEED SOME.
LONG TERM SECURE LOCAL OPTIONS
TO ACCOMMODATE YOU. WHO
OTHERWISE MIGHT BE TRANSFERRED
TO AN ADULT FACILITY AND THE OF
COURSE THE ACTION WE TOOK IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET WAS TRYING
TO PREVENT. THAT FROM HAPPENING
SO SB NINETY TO ESTABLISH A
SECURE YOUTH TREATMENT
FACILITIES. AND GIVES
GUIDELINES TO COUNTIES FOR THE
AD. EDUCATION HOUSING AND THE
SERVICE PROVISION FOR THOSE
YOU. IT ALSO SPECIFIES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
FACILITIES WILL FULLY CLOSE ON
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. SENATOR EYES. THANK
MADAM CHAIR THE MAJORITY OF
INCARCERATED YOUTH ARE HELD IN
COUNTY LEVEL FACILITIES LAST
YEAR GOVERNOR NEWSOM WORKED
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO FULLY
REALIGNED JUVENILE JUSTICE SO
THAT ALL YOUNG PEOPLE REMAIN IN
OUR COMMUNITIES INSTEAD OF
BEING HELD IN YOUTH PRISONS FAR
AWAY FROM THE RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO HEAL
TRAUMA AND CHANGE THE COURSE OF
THEIR LIVES THIS WAS A MOMENT
OF HOPE. THERE WAS ALSO
RECOGNITION THAT WE HAD TO GET
IT RIGHT AND IT WOULD NOT BE
EASY WE NEEDED TO FIND
ALTERNATIVES FOR ALL YOUTH
OFFENDERS FAILURE TO DO SO
WOULD RESULT IN MORE YOUNG
PEOPLE BEING TRIED AS ADULTS AS
A RESULT OF THESE CAREFUL
EFFORTS SB EIGHT TWENTY TWO
SIGNED INTO LAW AND IMPLEMENTED
A PLAN FOR CLOSING THE DIVISION
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE BY
TRANSFERRING THE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE CUSTODY TREATMENT AND
SUPERVISION OF YOU THROUGH THE
COUNTIES. SB EIGHT TWENTY THREE
ALLOCATED SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
TO COUNTIES TO PROVIDE SERVICES
AND IMPROVED FACILITIES TO
INCREASE THE LOCAL CAPACITY AND
SERVE THESE YOUTH. LAST YEAR SB
EIGHT TWENTY CODIFIED THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT LEGISLATURE
ATTEMPT. THE FABLESS EIGHT
SPECIAL DISPOSITIONAL TRACK. TO
BE USED AS AN ALTERNATIVE. TO
ADULT COURT PROSECUTION FOR
HIGHER NEED USE. THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A SECURE YOU
TREATMENT FACILITIES FOR HIGH
NEED YOUTH OR FOURTEEN OR OLDER
AND HAVE BEEN SENTENCED TO THE
SPECIAL DISPOSITIONAL TRACK. IT
PROVIDES GUIDANCE ON HOW
COUNTY'S LEGIT A CAPE HOUSE AND
FACILITATE SERVICES FOR THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE IT ALSO REQUIRES A
REHABILITATION PLAN. TO HELP
THEM ON THEIR PATH TO LEADING
MEANINGFUL LIVES AS CHAIR OF
SUB COMMITTEE FIVE I AM FOCUSED
ON OUR VISION FOR A BETTER
JUSTICE SYSTEM. I WILL WORK TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT THE NEW
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY IS ADEQUATELY
STAFFED. IT SHOULD BE RESOURCE
SO THAT TRUE ALIGNMENT FROM THE
CORRECTIONS SYSTEM. TO HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES IS REALIZED.
I CARE DEEPLY AS I'M SURE
EVERYONE HERE ABOUT THE
TRANSITION FROM A SYSTEM THAT
HAS BEEN SO DAMAGING TO OUR
YOUTH AND COMMUNITIES TOWARDS A
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM. THAT
PROVIDES HEALING RESTORATION
AND TRUE OPPORTUNITY FOR CHANGE.
AND GROWTH THANK YOU. SENATOR
NEAR. BUT A PRESENT RACISM OF
THE SENATE I WOULD URGE YOU TO
WAX CAUTIOUS ON THIS CONTINUED
REFORMS. EVERY TIME THERE'S A
MAJOR REFORM BILL AND THE NEXT
YEAR WE HAVE TO DO A CLEAN UP.
IT'S TESTIMONY THAT THE FIRST
BILL WAS NOT VERY WELL THOUGHT
OUT. THAT'S THE STANDARD
PROCEDURE AROUND HERE. NOW THE
REALIGNMENT OF THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM OR RATHER I
WOULD SAY TURNING IT INSIDE
OUT. IS NOT GONNA REALLY AND
YOU'RE THE BENEFIT OF ANYBODY.
IT'S GOING TO CREATE PROBLEMS
IS WHAT I CALL THE PONTIUS
PILOT THE STATE WASHES ITS
HANDS OF THESE WARS THEY WERE
CALLED WARD. AND A DOUBLE THE
COUNTY'S. CARRIERS WILL NEVER
SAY THEY'VE GOTTEN ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO DEAL WITH THIS
POPULATION. THEY'VE HAD TROUBLE
WITH DEALING WITH WHAT THEY HAD
FORMALLY HAD IN FACT SOME
COUNTIES HAD THE CONSENT FORM
CONSORTIUMS OF FACILITIES TO
HOUSE THE PRE REFORM. JUVENILE
OFFENDERS THAT WERE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND NOW MANY MORE
ARE DESCENDING UPON. ALSO THE
PRIMARY MISSION OF THE JUVENILE
SYSTEM IS THE REHABILITATION OF
THE LORD. I SUBMIT COUNTIES DO
NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES. I
SUBMIT THAT I'VE ALWAYS CALLED
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE RICHTER TREATMENTS
INADEQUATE TO FOR THOSE
JUVENILE LORCH BUT MOST
ASSUREDLY I BELIEVE THAT IS
GOING TO BE THE CASE WITHIN OUR
COUNTIES. THERE WILL BE
PROBLEMS BE ADVISED. AND DON'T
BE SURPRISED IF THERE'S ANOTHER
CLEAN UP BILL ON THE FLOOR HERE
NEXT YEAR. I URGE AND NOBLE. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. THING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
SKINNER. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SO FOR THOSE-
MEMBERS WHO. EITHER WERE NOT
PART OF THE LEGISLATURE WHEN WE
ADOPTED THE. ACTION ON DJJ
REALIGNMENT OR FOR THOSE WHO
MAY- WE DON'T ALWAYS REMEMBER
ALL THE DETAILS- I JUST WANT TO
BRING TO OUR ATTENTION THAT THE
NUMBER OF JUVENILES HOUSED IN
STATE RUN FACILITIES PEAK AT
TEN THOUSAND IN THE LATE
NINETEEN NINETIES IT WAS IN
THE- OF A- LITTLE UNDER THREE
THOUSAND SAY TEN YEARS AGO
TODAY IT IS ONLY SEVEN HUNDRED.
AND THAT NUMBER IS DUE TO THE
FACT THAT COUNTIES THE MAJORITY
OF OUR COUNTIES HAVE SENT TO
EITHER KNOWN OR VERY FEW USE TO
DJJ FACILITIES OVER THE LAST
FORTY FIVE YEARS IN FACT OF THE
OVER THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
JUVENILE COURT DISPOSITIONS IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. ONLY THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE WORK
COMMITTED TO DJJ AS COMPARED TO
FIVE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE THAT WERE COMMITTED
TO A SECURED COUNTY FACILITY SO
AS I MENTIONED THIS. ACTION IS
VERY MUCH IN OUR ARE REFLECTIVE
OF THE DIRECTION THAT OUR
COUNTIES HAVE BEEN MOVING IN
FOR SOME TIME NOW AND AS
INDICATED THESE ARE ON SOME
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE
BATES. BAKER I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI COURT
TESTING HI DALLY. NO DODD HI
THE RAZA I EGGMAN HI GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG
HI HUESO HI HER TADO NO JONES
NO KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE FIVE MELENDEZ NO MAN
I NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO BUT CHAU
VOGUE NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER HI
AMBERG I BY CASKEY FIVE WIENER
AYE WILK NOW. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES FORTUS.
IS TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES. I'M MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
SENATE THIRD READING AND WILL
TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
CENTER LEYVA IS PREPARED PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL TWO NINETY
FOUR BY SENATOR LEYVA AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC AND TRY
RETIREMENT AND MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE. SIR
LEYVA THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS SB TWO NINETY
FOUR REMOVES THE TWELVE YEAR
MAXIMUM SERVICE CREDIT CAP THAT
CAN BE EARNED BY AN EDUCATOR.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES AND
EDUCATORS CAN TAKE A LEAVE FROM
THEIR JOB TO ACT AS A STEWARD
OR REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
RESPECTIVE STATE OR NATIONAL
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION. THE
UNION REPRESENTATIVES MAY SPENT
SEVERAL YEARS WORKING AWAY FROM
THE OFFICE OR CLASSROOM
ADVOCATING FOR IMPROVED WORKING
CONDITIONS AND EMPLOYEE RIGHTS.
BY SERVICE KEPT IS NOT APPLIED
EVERY PUBLIC EMPLOYEE INCLUDING
PEACE OFFICERS FIREFIGHTERS AND
CITY AND COUNTY EMPLOYEES IT
DOES APPLY TO EDUCATORS SB TWO
NINETY FOUR SIMPLY REMOVE SAYS
TWELVE YEAR CAP TO ENSURE THE
EDUCATORS HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AS OTHER STATE
EMPLOYEES. THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES.
BAKER FIVE FORGES. BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO AYE CORTESE AYE DALY
NO DODD. HI TERRAZZA AYE EGGMAN.
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. I HER TADO
HI JONES NO KAMLAGER I LAYERED
AYE LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE AYE
MELINDA'S. NO MAN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH. NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. HI AMBERG I
WHAT CUSTODY I WIENER AYE WILK
NOW PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES FOR JUST. EGGMAN
I. NINETY NINE NO SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. I DON'T NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN CENTER ARCHULETA.
HE IS READY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION TWENTY BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA RELATIVE TO TARDIVE
DYSKINESIA AWARENESS WEEK.
UNDER THE FORAGERS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO BRING FORTH SR TWENTY
RECOGNIZING THE FIRST FULL WEEK
OF MAY AS PART AYE DYSKINESIA
AWARENESS WEEK AS YOU KNOW MAY
IS MENTAL HEALTH MONTH AN
IMPORTANT TIME TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE ONE IN FIVE ADULTS LIVING
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS. MANY
PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS CHRONIC
MENTAL ILLNESS REQUIRE
TREATMENT WITH MEDICATION.
WHILE ONGOING TREATMENT WITH
THESE MEDICATIONS CAN BE VERY
HELPFUL AND EVEN LIFESAVING FOR
MANY PEOPLE IT CAN ALSO LEAD TO
TAR DIVE DYSKINESIA. PART I.
BECAUSE THE MEASURE IT'S A
MOVEMENT DISORDER THAT IS
CHARACTERIZED BY RANDOM
INVOLUNTARY UNCONTROLLED
MOVEMENTS OF DIFFERENT MUSCLES
THROUGHOUT THE PERSON'S BODY.
IT MAY IMPACT THE MUSCLES
ASSOCIATED WITH JOAQUIN SPEECH
EATING AND EVEN BREATHING.
GARDAI DYSKINESIA THAT
DEVELOPED MONTHS YEARS AND
DECADES AFTER PERSON STARTS
TAKING THESE MEDICATIONS AND
EVEN AFTER THEY HAVE
DISCONTINUED USE OF THEM. NOT
ALL OF THESE PATIENTS DEVELOPED
HARD DRIVE DYSKINESIA BUT IT
DEVELOPS AND IS OFTEN PERMANENT.
PATIENTS SUFFERING FROM PART I
DYSKINESIA OFTEN SUFFER
EMBARRASSMENT DUE TO ABNORMAL
INVOLUNTARY MOVEMENTS WHICH
LEADS THEM TO WITHDRAW FROM
SOCIETY. THESE ARE FOLKS TRYING
TO LIVE AND FUNCTION IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND UNFORTUNATELY
THE LACK OF AWARENESS ABOUT
THIS DISEASE CREATES A STIGMA.
THE MORE WE CAN BRING AWARENESS
TO THE STILLNESS OF ALL MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES TO THE FOREFRONT
THE MORE WE CAN REMOVE THE
TERRIBLE STIGMA AROUND. TARDAR
DYSKINESIA IS OFTEN
UNRECOGNIZED IN PATIENTS
SUFFERING FROM THE ILLNESS ARE
COMMONLY MISDIAGNOSED BUT THERE
IS SOME HOPE. SEVERAL YEARS
AGO. RESEARCHERS BEGAN AND SO
NOW TO NEW TREATMENT FOR
TARDIVE DYSKINESIA HAVE BEEN
APPROVED BY THE FDA PROVIDE
RELIEF TO THOSE WHO HAVE
SUFFERED FROM THIS TERRIBLE
DISEASE. WE CAN ONLY HOPE THAT
THE MORE WE EDUCATE PEOPLE
ABOUT THIS DISEASE THE MORE WE
CAN FIND WAYS TO CURE IT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SAYING
NINE MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM. SAYING
NINE FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY NINE.
SENATOR MELENDEZ SHE IS READY
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE NINETEEN BY
SENATOR MELENDEZ AND ACTUALLY
DENTAL INDIA'S. SENATOR
MELENDEZ THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- SB
THREE NINETEEN WHICH IS
SPONSORED BY THE DESERT VALLEYS
BUILDERS ASSOCIATION MAKE A
SIMPLE CHANGE TO THE MITIGATION
FEE ACT BY CLOSING A LOOPHOLE
RELATED TO ANNUAL REPORTS
CURRENTLY IS THE LAWS WRITTEN
IN AGENCIES OBLIGATED TO
PROVIDE ANNUAL REPORTS
IDENTIFYING REVENUES COLLECTED.
IN EXPENDED IN THE SPACE SKEWS
ME SPECIFIC USE OF THOSE FUNDS
SHOULD THE AGENCY FAILED TO
PROVIDE SUCH REPORTS FOR AT
LEAST THREE CONSECUTIVE YEARS
THE PUBLIC OR PRIVATE ENTITY
MAY REQUEST AN AUDIT OF THIS
FUND ACCOUNTS OF THE AGENCIES
EXPENSE. UNFORTUNATELY THE
SCOPE OF THE AUDIT IS NOT
DEFINED SB THREE NINETEEN SEEKS
TO FIX THIS BY REQUIRING AN
ENTITY AUDIT EACH YEAR THE
AGENCY FAILED TO PROVIDE ANNUAL
REPORTS THIS SIMPLE CHANGE
WOULD INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
ENSURE THE GENERAL PUBLIC
INDOOR BUILDERS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW. IN
QUESTION NEW OR ADJUSTED FEES
THIS MEASURE HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND PASSED A POLICY COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUSLY AND I ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. IS THERE ANY TO OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE THIS ITEM IS ALSO ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION. SEEING IT
NO OBJECTION I THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON MEMBERS TO ITEM NUMBER FORTY
CENTER EGGMAN SHE IS READY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
FORTY EIGHT BY SENATOR EGGMAN
AND ACTUALLY DO THE
TRANSPORTATION. CENTER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. TWO BILLS OF
TODAY EXCUSE ME THIS IS A
SIMPLE BUILD A FOLLOWING AMONG
LEGISLATION I DID- SOME YEARS
BACK WITH THAT DATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CATHARINE BAKER. THIS
BILL ESTABLISH THE TRI VALLEY
SAN JOAQUIN REGIONAL RAIL
AUTHORITY AND TASKED WITH
IDENTIFYING DELIVERING THE
PROJECT TO LINK THE ACE IN THE
BAR CARE BY IMPROVING THE
CONNECTIVITY. THIS BILL JUST
MAKES SOME TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
LANGUAGE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SAYING NINE MEMBERS IF
THERE IS NO OBJECTION THIS IS
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTION
I IS THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
FORTY ONE WHICH IS ALSO A IN A
SENATOR EGGMAN BILL. PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FORTWENTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR EGGMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
FLOORS YOUR CENTER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE TODAY I'D LIKE
TO PRESENT AS BEFORE TWENTY
SEVEN THAT HAS TO DO WITH WATER
THEFT THAT'S RIGHT OUR PRECIOUS
COMMODITY CAN SOMETIMES BE
STOLEN FROM ONE AGENCY I
OFTENTIMES IS HIGHER THIS IS
THAT HAPPENS WITH PEOPLE
HOOKING UP TO. A FIRE HYDRANTS
IF THEY HAVE A CONSTRUCTION
SITE OR SOMETHING THE FEES
RIGHT NOW ARE VERY LOW- THE
FEES YOU'RE GOING TO BRAVE THE
FEES TO BE. COMMENSURATE WITH
THE CRIME OF STEALING WATER AND
POTENTIALLY CONTAMINATING AT
FIRST RANKING WATER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
THE- IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE- SINGMAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES. BAKER FIVE
FORGES. BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I
CORTES E. I. DOLLY PARTON HI
DODD FIVE TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. HI HER
TADO I JONES HI KAMLAGER. I
LAYERED AYE LEYVA. I MCGUIRE.
AYE MELINDA'S AYE MIN AYE
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I A CHIRLA
BOTH I PAN AYE PORTANTINO. HI
ROTH AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER. HI
NUMBER ONE I BY CAL SKI I
WIENER AYE WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
FORTUS. I THIRTY SIX NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE HAD ITEM
NUMBER FORTY TWO SENATOR
CORTESE HE IS PREPARED PLEASE
READ. PERFECT MINIATURE PLEASE
EXCUSE ME SENATOR SHE NEEDS TO
READ IT FIRST AND THEN AND THEN
THERE'S- SENATE BILL THIRTY
THREE BY SENATOR CORTEZ HE AN
ACT RELATING TO APPRENTICESHIPS.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SENATORS
THANK YOU THE AMOUNT YOU'RE A
POLICE PERSON SB THIRTY THREE
SB THIRTY THREE ESTABLISHES A
CONSTRUCTION APPRENTICESHIP
ADVANCEMENT TASK FORCE TO STUDY
AND REPORT ON BEST PRACTICES
FOR CREATING A MORE DIVERSE AND
INCLUSIVE INDUSTRY. DESPITE
GROWING EFFORTS AROUND OUR
REACH RECRUITMENT REPORTING
REPRESENTATION DISPARITIES
AMONGST WOMEN AND OTHERS- IN
THE UNDER REPRESENTED MINORITY
POPULATIONS IN THE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES SECTOR.
PERSIST TO THIS DAY EXPLORING
UNDERSTANDING BEST PRACTICES
WILL HELP ATTRACT MORE TALENT
WHICH IS CRITICAL FOR INDUSTRY
RESPECTFULLY- SPHEROIDAL THANK
YOU. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE. THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IF THERE IS
NO OBJECTION. SEEING NOW
OBJECTION IS THIRTY SIX NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. ITEM NUMBER
FORTY THREE SENATOR DR SO SHE
IS PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWO NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR DORADO AN ACT RELATING
TO SUBSURFACE INSTALLATIONS
CENTER TO THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. SB TWO
NINETY SEVEN WOULD CREATE A
CIVIL PENALTY OF UP TO ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR AN
OPERATOR OR EXCAVATOR WHO AFTER
FAILING TO FOLLOW DIG ALERT
REQUIREMENTS. DAMAGES A
SUBSURFACE INSTALLATION AND
CAUSES THE RELEASE OF HAZARDOUS
GAS OR LIQUID. CURRENTLY IF
YOU'RE GOING TO EXCAVATE AROUND
THE SUB SERVICE INSTALLATION
YOU'RE REQUIRED BY LAW TO CALL
THE EIGHT ONE ONE NOTIFICATION
CENTER. TO ENSURE THAT YOU
DON'T DAMAGE SOME CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BURIED BENEATH
THE SURFACE. THIS IS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT PROVIDES
OUR ENERGY WATER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND SO ON.
IT IS NO SMALL THING WHEN AN
EXCAVATOR FAILS TO MAKE THIS
CALL. DAMAGING SOME THINGS
BELOW THE SURFACE IS NOT ONLY
COSTLY AND POTENTIALLY
DESTRUCTIVE. BUT IT CAN ALSO BE
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS TO THE
WORKERS AND THE PUBLIC. THIS
BILL IS AN HONOR ONE SUCH
WORKER WHO TRAGICALLY LOST HIS
LIFE IN THE SOLAR COMPANY
FAILED TO CALL EIGHT ONE ONE
AND DAMAGED A GAS LINE.
SOCALGAS EMPLOYEE WOULD KILL
PATRICK AND HIS CREW WERE
CALLED OUT TO FIX THE PROBLEM.
AND DURING THE WORK THE LEAKING
GAS WAS IGNITED AND MYSTICAL
PATRICK WAS KILLED IN THE
EXPLOSION. THIS TRAGEDY COULD
HAVE BEEN AVOIDED HAD THE SOLAR
COMPANY FOLLOWED THE LAW. MORE
SIGNIFICANT PENALTIES WILL
PUNISH THE BAD ACTORS AND
HOPEFULLY PROVIDE SOME
INCENTIVE FOR OTHERS TO SIMPLY
CALL. EIGHT ONE ONE I ASK FOR
YOUR I. WILL. IF ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE THIS MEASURE IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION. SAYING
NINE ICE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. LIVING ON THE
ITEM NUMBER FORTY SIX SENATOR
LAYERED. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FORTY EIGHT
EIGHTY NINE BY SENATOR LAYERED
AND ACTUALLY DO THE PAST
CONTROL. ENTER THEIR THIRD THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. SB FORTY NINE SIX TO
INCREASE PARTICIPATION ON THE
AGRICULTURAL PEST CONTROL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE BY ADJUSTING
THE NUMBER OF BOARD MEMBERS
REPRESENTING THE GENERAL PUBLIC
IT WILL INCREASE BY ONE.
THERE'S BEEN REAL EXPERIENCE
WITH THIS ON THE CENTRAL COAST
WITH VARIOUS AERIAL SPRAYING
AND OTHER THINGS AND BRING THE
PUBLIC ALONG WILL REALLY HELP
AND MAKE THE PROCESS
TRANSPARENT IT PASSED THE
SENATE AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUSLY WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE- ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. SEEING NONE I IS
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES. BEHIND ITEM FORTY SEVEN
SENATOR JONES MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR JONES
AND ACTUALLY INTO FOSTER CARE
CENTER THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SB
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR WILL REQUIRE
RESOURCE FAMILIES ALSO KNOWN AS
FOSTER FAMILIES. TO BE TRAINED
ON HOW TO CARE FOR FOSTER YOUTH
WHO ARE AT RISK OF EXPERIENCING
CHILD LABOR TRAFFICKING IS
CRITICAL THAT WE PROTECT THESE
YOUTH FROM BECOMING A
TERRIFYING STATISTIC. FOSTER
PARENTS MUST BE PROVIDED WITH
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING THAT
FOCUSES ON THE DIVERSE NEEDS OF
FOSTER YOUTH INCLUDING THE
PREVENTION OF CHILD LABOR
TRAFFICKING. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THREE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SAYING
NINE THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION. SAYING NINE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. ITEM NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE GATE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SIX EIGHTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKIING AND
ACTUALLY IN THE CIVIL ACTIONS.
SENATOR THE FORAGERS MEN
PRESIDENT SO SOMETIMES YOU GET
A SITUATION WERE A CREDITORS
LENDING MONEY TO SOMEONE AND
THEY WANT TO DO A CONFESSION OF
JUDGMENT AND THAT BASICALLY
PERMITS THE CREDITOR TO
UNILATERALLY DECIDE IF SOMEONE
IS BREACHED THE CONTRACT.
ENTIRELY BY PASSING THE COURTS
AND GOING DIRECTLY TO SEIZING
THE ASSETS IT'S NOT. THE
COMMONPLACE OCCURRENCE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THIS EXISTS IN
THIS BILL SIX EIGHT EIGHT
ELIMINATES THE USE OF
COMPASSIONATE JUDGMENTS FOR
BOTH CONSUMER AND COMMERCIAL
LOANS AND IRISH AND I'VE OF.
THERE ANY RARE DISEASE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SAYING NINE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BAKER FIVE FORGES.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HIGH
COURT HAS HE HI DALLY NO NO
DODD. HI TORONTO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES NOPE KAMLAGER I
GLARED I LEYVA HI MCGUIRE. I
MELENDEZ NO MAN. HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO OCHO BOTH NO HAN. HI
PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER. HI AMBERG I BY CASKEY
I WIENER AYE WILK. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
FOR JUST. HIS TWENTY NO PRICE
TWENTY NINE NO SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FORTY NINE SENATOR
GLAZERS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN SIXTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR GLAZER AN
ACTOR LEADING TO CAL WORKS
CENTER THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS- THIS LEGISLATION BILL
BUILDS UPON. A BILL LAST
SESSION WHICH ALLOWED
QUALIFYING LOW INCOME STUDENT
PARENTS ENROLLED IN PUBLICLY
FUNDED COLLEGES FULL OR PART
TIME TO RECEIVE POWER BENEFITS
FOR UP TO FOUR YEARS AND
RECEIVE FUNDS TO PURCHASE BOOKS
PRIOR TO THE BEGINNING OF THE
ACADEMIC TURN. THIS BILL
EXPANDS THAT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENT PARENTS TO RECEIVE- CAL
WORK BENEFITS BY ADDING
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
PRIVATE NOT FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTIONS. AND CLARIFIES
THAT ALL INSTRUCTIONAL HOURS
INCLUDE SUMMER SESSION CLASSES.
AT THE IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE
INSURE. ALL STUDENT PARENTS
INCLUDING THOSE IN PRIVATE NOT
FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPLETE THEIR
COLLEGE EDUCATION BEFORE THEIR
ELIGIBILITY ON CAL WORKS ENDS.
SB SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT ENSURES
THAT THESE HARD WORKING
STUDENTS RECEIVE THE SUPPORT
NECESSARY TO COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SINGMAN
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION. SINGMAN ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY SENATOR BAKER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVENTY NINE
BY SENATOR BACKER AND ACTUALLY
INTO EMPLOYMENT CENTER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I'M EXCITED TO PRESENT
SB SEVEN SEVEN NINE. BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIANS WITH
BUILDERS TO IMPLANT. CLICK ON
HOMELESS POPULATION ARE
VETERANS BERMAN INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS STRUGGLE TO EARN A
LIVING. WHAT'S THE BEST WAY TO
BOUNCE BACK IS TO SUPPORT
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE SKILLS
BASED TRAINING. AND EMPLOYMENT
AT THE SAME TIME. EMPLOYMENT
SOCIAL ENTERPRISES- ESCS. AND
WORKER CO OPS. RIGHT INNOVATIVE
EVIDENCE BASED APPROACHES TO DO
THIS. I HAVE SHOWN THEY CAN
JUST DECREASE RECIDIVISM. AND
ALSO BREAK CYCLES OF
HOMELESSNESS. SB SEVEN SEVEN
NINE IS NOT A MANDATE IS A
RECOGNITION OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF THESE MODELS. BUT THE MODEL
LIKE THIS BY ROBERTS ENTERPRISE
DEVELOPMENT FOUNDATION. THEY
OPEN MY EYES TO SOCIAL
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. TWENTY FOUR
YEARS AGO. MODELS LIKE HOMEBOY
INDUSTRIES THAT EMPLOY SIX
HUNDRED RECENT INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS- FOR FORMER GANG
MEMBERS WELL PUTTING THEM
THROUGH AN EIGHTEEN MONTH
TRAINING PROGRAM. FOR GOOD WILL
ENTERPRISES EMPLOYS NINETEEN
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS 85% IN
THIS CATEGORY. FRANKLY SEEN OUR
COMMITMENT TO EARN AND LEARN
PROGRAMMES WILL BE GIVING THESE
CALIFORNIANS WITH AREAS TO
IMPLEMENT. AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
OVERTIME SUSTAIN THEMSELVES
REDUCE OUR DEPENDENCE ON
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS. AND
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES. BUT
THIS BILL I'M HAPPY TO SAY
PASSED WITH UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND THE
SENATE LABOR COMMITTEE AND
COLLEAGUES ESPECIALLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. SENATOR ALAN.
BOB OF BURGER BUT SENATOR I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
YOUR FIRST BILL TO THE FLOOR
TODAY. HI I JUST MY
UNDERSTANDING YOU'RE CHANGING
VARIOUS DEFINITIONS ONE OF THE
FACT IT MEANS A LOT TO ME. AND
SO I THINK THAT THIS BILL
DEMANDS A LITTLE MORE SCRUTINY
THAN THAT AND THEN THE- NOT AS
SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE SO. I YOU KNOW
I I'D LIKE YOU TO TALK A BIT
ABOUT SOME OF THE DEFINITE SO
WHICH OF THE DEFINITIONS THAT
YOU'RE CHANGING OR ADDING TO.
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
INNOVATION OPPORTUNITY ACT.
WHICH OF THOSE DEFINITIONS OF
THEIR FAVORITE CHANGE AND WHY.
PLEASE TELL. THAT CHANGES WELL.
WELL THANK SENATOR WE'RE ADDING
MODELS LAKE THESE IN SO AND-
YOUR. EIGHT AND- COOPER. TO THE
DEFINITION OF A CAN BE- AND
LEARN PROGRAM. BUT BUT WHY WHY
IS THAT IMPORTANT TO YOU AND
WHY WHY IS IT YOUR FAVORITE. IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT REALLY
ENABLES THAT THE HEART OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU SENATOR. Q.
PROVIDE. MORE FUNDING FOR THESE
OR TO LEARN PROGRAMS THAT THE
FUTURE OF WORK COMMISSION GETS
ISSUED ITS FINAL REPORT. AND
RECOMMENDED THAT WE DO THIS
THAT THE STATE MOVED MORE
SUPPORT TO THESE OR LEARN
PROGRAMS LIKE IMPLEMENT SOCIAL
ENTERPRISES AND IS THAT
LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS US TO DO
THAT. MEMBERS OF MY I
APPRECIATE YOUR DILIGENCE BUT
YOU KNOW THAT EVEN SIMPLER
SOCIAL ENTERPRISE
EXTRAORDINARILY- BUREAUCRATIC.
TO ME AND I WOULD LIKE A KIND
OF A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
WHO CAME UP WITH THIS TITLE AND-
AND HOW IT CAN POSSIBLY BE
JUSTIFIED WITHOUT ALL RESERVE
THE REST MY QUESTIONS. WELL
IT'S NOT ME WHO CAME UP WITH
IT. AND IT IS WE DO A LOT OF
GUYS ACRONYMS IN GOVERNMENT BUT
IT IS A PARTICULARLY AFTER ONE
THAT THESE ARE BUSINESSES. THAT
EMPLOY PEOPLE PROBABLY TRAIN
THEM. K. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
YEAH QUESTION- TWO QUESTIONS
ACTUALLY FOR THE AUTHOR IF I
CAN MANAGE HERE- YES M. F. D.
WITH RESPECT TO THIS DEATH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE TAKE
QUESTIONS BUT YES A YEAR WITH
RESPECT TO THE DEFINITION OF
AN- THESE EMPLOYMENT- BUT YOU
FIND IT SOCIAL ENTERPRISES IT
INDICATES TWO THINGS THAT I
THINK ARE QUITE CRITICAL HERE
ONE THAT AS THE REQUIREMENTS
SAY THAT IT'S EVIDENCE BASED
AND UTILIZES DATA DRIVEN
POLICIES TO MAKE SUCH
DETERMINATIONS IS THE CASE AND
SECONDLY IT BROADLY DEFINES
PRODUCES GOODS TO PROVIDE
SERVICES IS THERE ANY
LIMITATIONS ON WHAT KIND OF
GOODS COULD FOR EXAMPLE IN THIS
PROGRAM INCLUDE THE PRODUCTION
OF GUNS. OR BAZOOKAS OR
WHATEVER WHO IS ARE SOME
LIMITATION IN TERMS YOUR
DEFINITIONS QUESTIONS THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG YOUR MICHAEL FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS. THE ENTERPRISES ARE
NOT BROADLY DEFINED IN THIS
PROVISION. BUT OVER TIME WE
WANT TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAMS
LIKE I MENTIONED HOMEBOY
INDUSTRIES A GOODWILL
INDUSTRIES AT THE COMMUNITY
HOUSING PARTNERSHIPS IN SAN
FRANCISCO THAT IS SOLUTIONS
ASSET. THAT EMPLOYEES ARE
FORMERLY HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
AND TRAIN THEM TO BE FRONTLINE
DIFFERENT DESK WORKERS THESE
ARE THE KIND OF PROGRAMS THAT
ARE VISION BY THIS LEGISLATION.
CONFEDERAL QUICK IS A LITTLE
YOU JUST SIMPLY SAY SERVICES OR
OR OR OR GOODS YOU INDICATE
THAT WHAT YOUR INTENTION IS BUT
THE LANGUAGE OF THE MEASURE
DOESN'T SAY THAT. WELL SINCE
THIS IS A- NOT A MANDATE IT IS
ULTIMATELY UP TO THE LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS TO
DO ISSUE THAT FUNDING SO I WILL
LEAVE IT TO THEIR DISCRETION TO
LEAVE OUT THE KINDS OF
BUSINESSES. THAT YOU MENTIONED.
PERFECT SENATOR WIENER AND
SENATOR BAKER IF THERE ARE ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS IF YOU'D LIKE
TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS IN
YOUR CLOSING THAT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE AS WELL SENATOR
WIENER. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. A. B.
WELL- SO YES SIR YES OKAY- SO
YOU INTERESTED IN THIS IT HAS A
DEFINITION OF- QUOTE WORKER
COOPERATIVES. AND THAT
DEFINITION IS IN THE
CORPORATION'S CODE AFTER I FIND
OUT A LITTLE BIT OFFENSIVE
BECAUSE WORKERS COOPERATIVES
ABOUT. YOU KNOW POWER TO THE
PEOPLE AND THE CORPORATIONS
CODE IS SORT OF CORPORATE AND
SO I'M JUST WONDERING HOW YOU
JUSTIFY DEFINING SOMETHING SO
IMPORTANT ABOUT A WORKERS
COOPERATIVE. IN THE
CORPORATION'S CODE CAN USE US
JUSTIFY THAT. BUT IN THE OF
TIME ARE THERE ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS. LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SINCE I NEED TO CHAIR
THIS. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NINETY SENATOR BAKER OU ME
WRAP THIS ALL UP BY ANSWERING
ALL THOSE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
THANKS TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE
GENTLE ADDRESSING HERE TODAY-
ON AN IMPORTANT TOPIC. OF THESE
EMPLOYMENT SOCIAL ENTERPRISES
THAT ROOF IN RESPONSE TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO'S
QUESTIONS- I BELIEVE IT'S OKAY
THAT THE DEFINITIONS IN THE
CORPORATION'S QUOTE THE POINT
IS THESE WORKER COOPS. I NEED
TO BE SUPPORTED AND THEY NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING RIGHT NOW
ABOUT 1% OF OUR WORKFORCE
DOLLARS GO TO THESE MODELS.
THAT WILL BE A FUTURE WORK
COMMISSION SAID THAT WE SHOULD
GO UP TO A 30% FOR THESE
MODELS. SO IN THAT CONTEXT WITH
THESE COMMENTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
BUT SENATOR BAKER THIS WAS- ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. OF LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OBJECTION TO S. PROCEEDING
WITH IT. LOOKS LIKE THERE IS AN
OBJECTION THERE ARE MORE THAN
ONE OBJECTION SO- ROLL CALL
PLEASE. ALLEN. ARCHULETA ATKINS.
FIVE BATES. BAKER I FOR JUST.
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. CORTEZ.
THREE DALLY. DODD THE RAZA.
EGGMAN GLAZER. GONZALEZ GROVE
NO HERTZBERG. HUESO HER TADO.
JONES NO KAMLAGER. LAYARD LEYVA.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. MEN
NEWMAN. NIELSEN BY A TRAVEL BUG.
NO PAN. PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO
SKINNER. AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI.
WIENER WILK NO PLEASE CALL UP-
SENATOR HERTZBERG. AT. K. ALL.
I CAN'T. SENATOR HERTZBERG.
MAKE A MOTION FOR UNANIMOUS
LOCAL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THERE I.
FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO. I
MEASURE PASSES. CONGRADULATIONS
CENTER BAKER MEMBERS ARE MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY THREE.
SENATOR LIMON. ARE YOU PREPARED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR LIMóN RELATIVE TO
FINANCIAL CAPABILITY MONTH
CENTER THEM ON THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEMBERS SR TWENTY SEVEN DECLARE
IS THE MONTH OF APRIL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE HAS A FINANCIAL
CAPABILITY MONTH TO RAISE
PUBLIC AWARENESS ABOUT THE
CONTINUING NEED TO INCREASE
FINANCIAL CAPABILITY CALIFORNIA
HAS PASSED NUMEROUS PIECES OF
LEGISLATION ON FINANCIAL
LITERACY BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN
BENEFIT FROM HAVING A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR
FINANCES. FINANCIAL EDUCATION
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO GENERATE
LONG TERM BENEFITS AND A STRONG
UNDERSTANDING OF THE BASICS IS
VITAL FOR EVERYONE TRYING TO
NAVIGATE TODAY'S COMPLEX
FINANCIAL LANDSCAPE. A LACK OF
FINANCIAL CAPABILITY IS A REAL
CONSEQUENCE FOR INDIVIDUALS
INCLUDING LOWER SAVINGS RATE
LOWER CREDIT SCORES AND LESS
WEALTH OVERALL. FOR STUDENTS
FINANCIAL EDUCATION CAN LEAD TO
RESPONSIBLE COLLEGE FINANCING
DECISIONS INCREASE SAVINGS AND
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
CREDIT ADDITIONALLY ARE USE ARE
SHOWING MORE AND MORE INTEREST
IN LEARNING ABOUT FINANCIAL
TOPICS. I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO RECOGNIZE SOME OF THE GREAT
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AND
COMMUNITY LENDERS WITH TRUSTED
FINANCIAL ADVISORS THAT PROVIDE
FINANCIAL EDUCATION TO OUR
COMMUNITY. FOR INSTANCE IN
TWENTY TWENTY THEIR
INSTITUTIONS THAT PROVIDED
ALMOST NINE THOUSAND STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA WITH FINANCIAL
LITERACY PROGRAM CALLED BITE OF
REALITY THAT TEACHES STUDENTS
HOW TO PROPERLY BUDGET
ASSIGNING THEM AN IDENTITY AND
SHOWING THEM HOW TO NAVIGATE
ADULTHOOD. AND PROPERLY MANAGE
THEIR EXPENSES. WHAT THE
PROGRAM IS TO HELD IN PERSON.
DOZENS OF CREDIT UNIONS
ADJUSTED TO OFFER THE PROGRAM
ORIGINALLY DUE TO SAFETY
CONCERNS AND GUIDELINES FROM
CLUB IN NINETEEN. AFTER
COMPLETING THE PROGRAM STUDENTS
EXPRESSED AN OVERWHELMING
INTENDS TO CREATE AND FOLLOW
BUDGET SET SAVINGS GOALS AND
TRACK THEIR SPENDING. FINANCIAL
LITERACY RATES DIRECTLY IMPACT
THE FINANCIAL HEALTH OF
INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITIES GIVING US ALL A
REASON TO SUPPORT THE EFFORTS
TO INCREASE FINANCIAL
CAPABILITY AMONGST
CALIFORNIANS. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON SR TWENTY SEVEN.
SENATOR GLAZERS. HI IS THIS
YOUR FIRST BILL. IN THE SENATE
IS. I'M JUST THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION. SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS FIVE BATES.
BAKER. FIVE FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HIGH
COURT TESTING I DALY ALL RIGHT
FIVE DODD. HI TORONTO I EGGMAN
FIVE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG HI HUESO.
HI HER TADO. HURTADO I JONES
FIVE KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE
LEYVA I'VE MCGUIRE FIVE
MELENDEZ MAN I NEWMAN. I
NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH I PAN.
HI PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH AYE
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI I'M BURKE
FIVE WHITE HUSKY I WIENER AYE
WILK. I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. IT I THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY. SENATOR
WESSEL. HE IS PREPARED PLEASE
READ SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY
BY SENATOR HUESO RELATIVE TO
AUTISM AWARENESS MONTH. SENATOR
WEST SO THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU IN A PRISONER MEMBERS
SO I RISE TO PRESENT SR THIRTY
WHICH DESIGNATES THE MONTH OF
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS
AUTISM AWARE AWARENESS MONTH.
ENCOURAGES RESIDENTS TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AUTISM AWARENESS
AUTISM OR AUTISM SPECTRUM
DISORDER IS A DEVELOPMENTAL
CONDITION THAT AFFECTS THE
SOCIAL COMMUNICATION AND
BEHAVIORAL SKILLS OF
INDIVIDUALS BASED ON WHERE. ON
THE AUTISM SPECTRUM THEY FIND
THEMSELVES MORE THAN FIVE POINT
FOUR MILLION AMERICAN ADULTS
ARE WITHIN THE AUTISM SPECTRUM
MORE CHILDREN ARE BEING
DIAGNOSED ON THE AUTISM
SPECTRUM THAN EVER BEFORE WITH
DIAGNOSES AS HIGH AS ONE IN
FIFTY FOUR CHILDREN NATIONALLY.
INDIVIDUALS WITHIN THE AUTISM
SPECTRUM OFTEN REQUIRE
SPECIALIZED SUPPORT AND
COMMUNITY SUPPORT SERVICES TO
INSURE THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY.
UP WITH STRUGGLES ARISE INTO
THE DUE TO LACK OF SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES IT IS IMPORTANT TO
BUILD AN INCLUSIVE AND AWARE
ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL PEOPLE
INCLUDING THOSE WITH AUTISM.
THE FUEL DIVERSITY IN SUCCESS
ON ALL FACETS OF OUR SOCIETY.
HIGHLIGHTING APRIL WITH AS
AUTISM AWARENESS AWARENESS
MONTH WOULD GIVE STUDENTS
EDUCATORS AND FAMILIES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTIVELY UPLIFT
AND INSPIRE THOSE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES WITH THE ARTISTS ON
THE AUTISM SPECTRUM SO THAT
THEY CAN FEEL PROUD AND EMPOWER
WILL SEEK INCREASE RESOURCES.
AND AWARENESS AGAIN THIS
RESOLUTION DESIGNATES THE MONTH
OF APRIL TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS
AUTISM AWARENESS MONTH AND
ENCOURAGES RESIDENTS TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AUTISM AWARENESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THE SUPPORT
RESOLUTION. SENATOR PENN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT CENTERS I
TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS R.
THIRTY ONE I THINK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM SAN DIEGO FOR BRING
THIS FORWARD. AS A PEDIATRICIAN
WHO ACTUALLY- FOCUSES ON- TRIP-
DEVELOPMENT- BUT CERTAINLY IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE RAISE
AWARENESS OF AUTISM AND AUTISM
IS NOT JUST A CONDITION- TO BE
TREATED IN FACT WE OUGHT TO
EMBRACE THE NEURODIVERSITY OF
OUR POPULATION INCLUDES. PEOPLE
THE AUTISM TO ACCEPT THEM FOR
WHO THEY ARE- NOT THAT AS WELL
IN THAT- CERTAINLY ISN'T WE
HEAR IN CALIFORNIA HAVE TAKEN
STEPS TO BE SURE PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO TREATMENT AND TWO
OTHER SUPPORTS- IT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT. NOT ONLY BECAUSE YOU
KNOW PEOPLE DOCTORS AND AS WELL
AS THEIR FAMILIES AND TO THAT
END TO. RACISM WITH ACCEPTANCE
AS WELL- AND- WOULD MAKE NOTE
THAT IS NOTED IN THE RESOLUTION
THAT WHILE. THE NUMBER OF
DIAGNOSES OF AUTISM HAS RISEN
THAT'S ACTUALLY. MORE BECAUSE
WE NOW RECOGNIZE AND WE TRY TO
TAKE THE STIGMA AWAY- AND WE
STILL HAVE WORK TO DO THERE BUT
TO REMOVE THE STIGMA AROUND
AUTISM AS WELL AND- AGAIN
PROVIDE THAT HELP. AND WITH
THAT A- URGENT. AYE VOTE ON SR
THIRTY THANK YOU. SENATOR BAKER.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FOR BRING THIS RESOLUTION AS A
SEVEN AS MY BROTHER LOS
ARTISTIC AND I THINK HAVING
AWARENESS MUCH PARTICULAR
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
EARLY DETECTION CAN LEAD TO
TREATMENT WE'VE LEARNED A LOT
ABOUT TREATMENT AT THE EARLY
STAGES SO I THINK YOU AND I
URGE SUPPORT FOR THIS
RESOLUTION. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION. SAYING NINE ICE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS AND WE HAVE A SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OR ANY
MEMBER THAT WOULD LIKE AN ITEM
POOL FOR SEPARATE DISCUSSION.
SINGMAN ADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.SENATE BILL SEVEN OH
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY
FOUR SIXTY ONE AND ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTY TWO.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES BAKER I FOR JUST. HI
BRADFORD FIVE CABALLERO HI
CORTESE HI DOLLY AYE DODD I
TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH I HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO. HI HER TADO I JONES
I KAMLAGER HI LAYERED I LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ. MAN I
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF
BOTH. HI PAM BY PORTANTINO. HI
ROTH HI RUBIO I SKINNER HI
NUMBER I WE CASKEY I WIENER AYE
WILK I. FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO
ON CONSENT FIVE THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO ON SPECIAL CONTENT. MOVING
ON TO- COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SENATOR PORTANTINO YES MADAM
PRESIDENT THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WILL RECONVENE FIVE
MINUTES AFTER WE GAVEL DOWN
FROM THE SESSION VERY GOOD.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO RETURN TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS IS
THE TIME TO DO THE ADJOURNING
MEMORIES. SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
ARRIVED TODAY THERE I RECOGNIZE
A GREAT CALIFORNIA. A GREAT
AMERICAN I NBA LEGEND AND
CHAMPION FOR EQUALITY THAT IN
THE PERSON OF ELGIN BAYLOR. MR
BAILEY WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
WASHINGTON DC BUT HE SPENT THE
LAST SIXTY PLUS YEARS HERE IN
LOS ANGELES AND HE WILL BE
REMEMBERED AS A GREAT. ANGELINO
HE WAS A NUMBER ONE DRAFT PICK
IN NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT THE
ROOKIE OF YEAR IN NINETEEN
FIFTY NINE. AND ELEVEN TIME NBA
ALL STAR AND A MEMBER OF THE
BASKETBALL HALL OF FAME.
MEMBERS BEFORE THERE WAS DR J.
BUT JAMES WORTHY KEVIN MCHALE A
TIM DUNCAN LARRY BIRD CHARLES
BARKLEY WE CAN GO ON AND ON AND
ON OF AMAZING FORD'S WHO PLAYED
THERE WAS A GOLDEN BAYLOR HE
WAS THE FIRST FOUR WITH A JELLY
AND BALL HANDLING SKILLS HE WAS
TRULY THE FIRST OF ITS KIND IN
THE BLAZE A TRAIL FOR THOSE
GRADES AND SO MANY WHO FOLLOWED
AFTER HIM. THE LEGENDARY KAREEM
ABDUL JABBAR DESCRIBED BAYLOR
**** ME OF A ONE MAN GAME A
SOURCE OF INSPIRATION. HAS THE
BASKETBALL WRITER BOB RYAN
WROTE BAYLOR WAS THE MOST
INFLUENTIAL INDIVIDUAL
OFFENSIVE PLAYER IN THE LAST
SIXTY YEARS. AS A KID GROWING
UP IT WAS ONLY TWO BASKETBALL
CARD YOU WANT BUILDING BAYLOR
AN OSCAR ROBINSON AND I'D
VENTURE TO IMAGINE WHAT A OSCAR
FAILED IN BAYLOR CAR WOULD BE
WORTH TODAY. JERRY WEST WHO'S
ONE OF BAYLOR'S TEAMMATES
CALLED HIM ONE OF THE MOST
SPECTACULAR SHOOTERS THE GAME
HAS EVER KNOWN. TELL ME HAWKINS
ANOTHER TEAMMATE AND LATER NBA
BROADCASTER STATED PAUL PER
POUND NO ONE WAS EVER BETTER
AND GREATER THAN ELGIN BAYLOR.
DEALERS LEADERSHIP WAS NOT
LIMITED TO THE COURT. HE ALSO
FOUGHT GAINST RACISM RACISM
INCLUDING JIM CROW LAWS IN
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE WHEN THE
LAKERS WERE SCHEDULED TO PLAY
IN CINCINNATI WROTE THE
CINCINNATI ROLES IN WEST
VIRGINIA BAYLOR AND HIS
TEAMMATES WERE TOLD. BY THEIR
HOTEL MANAGER THOSE THREE COLOR
BOYS WILL HAVE TO STAY
SOMEWHERE ELSE THIS IS A NICE
RESPECTFUL HOTEL WE CAN'T TAKE
THOSE COLOR BOYS IN HERE. LATER
BAYLOR HIS TEAMMATES WENT OUT
TO EAT AND WE'RE DEBT OT
DENIED SERVICE AT A RESTAURANT
AS WELL BAYLOR DECIDED NOT TO
PLAY IN THE GAME AND INSTEAD
CALLED ATTENTION TO THE
INEQUALITIES THAT BLACK PEOPLE
FACE IN THE TOWN AND ACROSS THE
NATION. HE TOLD HIS TEAMMATES.
ALL I WANT TO DO IS BE TREATED
LIKE A HUMAN BEING. I'M NOT AN
ANIMAL PUT IN A CAGE AND LET
OUT FOR CO. THEY WON'T TREAT ME
LIKE AN ANIMAL. BAYLOR DID
DECADES BEFORE COLIN KAPERNICK
HE TOOK A KNEE IN PROTEST. HE
CLEARED THE WAY FOR ATHLETES TO
TAKE AN ACTIVE ROLE ëFIGHTING
INJUSTICE INCLUDING MANY NBA
PLAYERS WHO REACTED TO THE
GEORGE FLOYD MURDER LAST YEAR
BAYLOR ALSO SERVED HIS COUNTRY
AS A MEMBER THE U. S. ARMY
RESERVE AND WAS CALLED TO
ACTIVE DUTY DURING THE NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE NINETEEN SIXTY TWO.
SEASON DESPITE ONLY. I MISS BY
ONLY BEING ABLE TO PLAY ON THE
WEEKENDS HE STILL MANAGED TO
SCORE EIGHTEEN HUNDRED POINTS
THAT SEASON AND HELP LEAD THE
NBA LAKERS IN THE NBA FINALS.
HE PLAYED FOR FOURTEEN YEARS
UNFORTUNATELY HE NEVER CAPTURED
A CHAMPIONSHIP THOUGH HE PLAYED
A MANY CHAMPIONSHIP GAMES. AND
IT'S SOMEWHAT IRONIC HE RETIRED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE IN THE
NEXT YEAR THE LAKERS CAPTURED
THE CHAMPIONSHIP. IS SEVENTY
ONE POINT GAME RECORD. FROM
NINETEEN I MEAN FROM NOVEMBER
FIFTEENTH NINETEEN SIXTY STOOD
FOR FORTY SIX YEARS UNTIL KOBE
BRYANT BROKE IT IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX. HE WAS INDUCTED INTO
THE BASKETBALL HALL OF HALL OF
FAME IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN.
AND IS NUMBER TWENTY TWO JERSEY
WAS RETIRED BY THE LAKERS IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE HE SPENT
TWENTY TWO YEARS AS A GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE LOS ANGELES
CLIPPERS AND WAS NAMED NBA
EXECUTIVE OF THE YEAR IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE REGULAR SAID HE WAS FORCED
OUT OF HIS JOB BECAUSE OF AGE
AND REYES THEY CLAIM THAT WAS
ULTIMATELY DISMISSED IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. BUT ONLY THREE
YEARS LATER CLIPPERS OWNER
DONALD STERLING WAS BANNED FROM
THE NBA. FOR HIS LIFE AFTER. A
RECORDING HIM MAKING RACIST
REMARKS AND COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE PUBLIC. HOLDEN BAYLOR WILL
ALWAYS BE REMEMBERED AS A
CHAMPION WAS NEVER AFRAID TO
STAND UP. THROUGH ADVERSITY ON
AND OFF THE COURT. AND MY MOST
FONDEST MEMORY OF MR BAYLOR
INDIVIDUAL I AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MEET ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS WITH
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO WHEN HE
SHARED AROUND THE GOLF WITH ME.
AND THREE OTHERS AND DURING
THAT FOUR AND A HALF HOUR
AROUND HE NEVER TALKED ABOUT
HIMSELF HE WAS MORE INTERESTED
IN WHAT. WE DID AS A LIVING AND
WHAT WE WERE DOING IN THE
COMMUNITY AND THAT'S WHAT HE
WAS ALL ABOUT GIVING BACK IN
THE COMMUNITY HE PASSED AWAY AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTY SIX OF
NATURAL CAUSES ON MAY TWENTY
SECOND HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
LOVING WIFE. EILEEN AND HIS
CHILDREN CRYSTAL ALLEN AND
ALISON MEMBERS ACTUALLY TO JOIN
IN MEMORY OF A GREAT
CALIFORNIA. A GREAT AMERICAN
ELGIN BAYLOR. PLEASE BRING HIS
NAME FORWARD TO THE DESK SO HE
MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE.
SENATOR ALAN. MEMBERS IT'S WITH
A HEAVY HEART THAT I ASK THE
SENATE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
A CONSTITUENT OF MINE JEFF
FRANKEL. WHO IS ORIGINALLY FROM
LONDON ONTARIO CANADA YOU WAS
RAISED ALONG ISLAND AREA OF NEW
YORK AND AFTER ATTENDING STATE
UNIVERSITY OF NEW YORK AND-
BUFFALO. HE EMBARKED ON A
SUCCESSFUL CAREER IN MARKETING.
LOVED HIS JOB AS A MARKETING
CONSULTANT WORKING WITH BIG
COMPANIES LIKE KING WORLD
PRODUCTIONS SHARK NINJA. THE
FEDERAL. BUT EVENTUALLY MADE
ITS HOME IN CALIFORNIA HE WENT
TO THE PALACE VERDES PENINSULA
WHERE HE SCALED BACK HIS
MARKETING WORK SO WE COULD
SPEND MORE TIME VOLUNTEERING
WITH THE- LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND FOLLOWING HIS PASSION FOR
EDUCATION. VERY LOVING PARENT
AND ADVOCATE FOR PARENTS THE
FOR STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
ARE HE ALTERNATELY WAS ELECTED
TO THE SCHOOL BOARD JUST SIX
MONTHS AGO WE JUST GOT ELECTED
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
START NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY.
HE ALREADY SERVED ON THE-DISTRICT'S BUDGET ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THE PARCEL TAX
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE AN
APPOINTED MEMBER TO
SUPERINTENDENTS BUSHELL
EDUCATION PARENT ADVISORY GROUP
HE STEPPED UP THE SERVICE
COMMUNITY AND THE SCHOOL BOARD.
AND OF COURSE PASSED AWAY.
UNEXPECTEDLY JUST SIX MONTHS
LATER. AT THE YOUNG AGE OF
FIFTY EIGHT. HIS DAUGHTER
JILLIAN WAS INSPIRATION. AS A
FAMILY STRUGGLE TO FIND
SERVICES FOR JULIAN- WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS AND- JEFF STEPPED
UP THAT IS VOICE AS AN ADVOCATE
IN THE PASSWORD IS COMMUNITY
EMBRACED HIM AND HIS. EFFORTS
THOSE WHO NEED CHAPEL REMEMBER
HIS DEDICATION TO EQUITY AND
INCLUSION FOR ALL CHILDREN IN
THE TWENTY SIX SENATE DISTRICT.
HE PASSED AWAY UNEXPECTEDLY AS
I SAID JUST A FEWWEEKS AGO WAY
TOO SOON HE'S SURVIVED. BY HIS
DAUGHTER JILLIAN'S MOTHER
GLORIA FRANKEL IS SIBLINGS
KAREN ROSEN MARK FRANKEL IS
NIECE MINDY AND HIS NEPHEWS
DAVID LOUIS. AND KEVIN AND- AND
SOME FOLKS LOCAL LAW SOME LOCAL
FOLKS HAVE SAID THAT THE
COMMUNITY HAS REALLY BEEN BEEN
LEFT WITH A HUGE VOID AND SO
IT'S WITH A HEAVY HEART IN AND
DEEP SADNESS THAT I WANT TO ASK
US TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY AND I
WANT TO SEND MY DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY AND
TO THE ENTIRE PALACE VERDES.
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
COMMUNITY. PLEASE BRING HIS
NAME FORWARD TO THE DEATH SO HE
MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED. SENATOR OCHO BOTH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR-
RICE RETURNING MEMORY OF CAROL
BANNER WHO WAS A CONDITION OF
MINE FROM LAKE ARROWHEAD HERE
WAS A LONG TIME RESIDENT OF
LAKE ARROWHEAD WHERE SHE AND
HER HUSBAND DOING RAISE THEIR
FAMILY. SHE WAS ALSO VERY
ACTIVE MEMBER OF OUR COMMUNITY
SHE WAS INVOLVED IN NUMEROUS
BOARDS AGENCIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE RIM
OF THE WORLD UNIFIED SCHOOL
BOARD THE LAKE ARROWHEAD
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND THE RIM
OF THE WORLD ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. CAROL WAS A RESPECTED
REALTOR FOR OVER FORTY YEARS
AND SHE WAS WELL KNOWN FOR
BEING A CHAMPION FOR PRIVATE
PROPERTY RIGHTS. AND ADDRESSING
MANY LOCAL ISSUES. SHE LEFT
BEHIND AN HONORABLE LEGACY FOR
HER CHILDREN AND HER COMMUNITY.
SHE WILL BE DEARLY MISSED.
PLEASE BRING HER NAME FORWARD
TO THIS SO THAT SHE MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORY ALLIES BY
THE SENATE. IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU SO MUCH- LOTS OF WORK
AHEAD OF US BUT OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR THIS
THURSDAY MAY SIXTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CENTER. PRETEND
THE SENATE. WILL BE ADJOURNED
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE AM.